on this sunday night the investigation
into the linton fire
did the spark from a train lead to the
disaster in bc
the fire was underneath the train a
witness reveals
what he saw cross-border limits lifted
what you need to know america celebrates
july
4th even with the dangers of the variant
plus the gunnawage first nation makes
history with a new grand chief
the significance of this election
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight in british columbia
where crews are working tirelessly to
contain wildfires across the province
there are more than 170 fires burning in
bc
13 of them are being monitored closely
because of their threat to public safety
and for the next two weeks the canadian
armed forces will be helping with air
support
but the focus tonight is very much on
the fire that devastated the village of
litton
paul haysom joins us from the checkpoint
outside linton and paul what's the
situation there right now
robin a steady stream of emergency
vehicles have been entering the
community of litton after it was
decimated by
fire a fire that is still burning and
moving north
the province's wildfire service says
crews are making some progress on the
linton creek fire though it is still
considered out of control
investigators have yet to confirm what
caused this catastrophic blaze
we are beginning that investigation as
soon as it's safe for our people to get
in there
there are reports a cn train sparked
flames as a pass by linton
late wednesday afternoon during a
searing heat wave
this couple says they spotted that train
with flames underneath
as it continued on the tracks to the
nearby community of boston
bar was the train on fire gary phelps
and his wife alerted fire officials and
then went back to the scene to find a
much more serious situation
when we went by originally it was a very
small fire
and by the time we got back it was fully
engulfed and then the train started to
catch on fire and it was carrying wood
and that kind of stuff
and the train was fully engulfed global
news cannot independently confirm those
details though there was a fire crew and
a cn vehicle spotted at the scene
in a statement to global news cnn said
it will offer its full assistance to
help authorities identify the causes
of this tragic event the bc coroner
service was finally able to enter linton
on saturday confirming the deaths of two
people
it will likely be some time yet before
residents are able to survey the damage
for themselves
a provincial order has restricted public
entry into the fire zone
violating that order could result in an
eleven hundred and fifty dollar fine
there are a dozen other fires of note in
the province and about 20 areas under
evacuation order or alert
though much of southeastern b.c is
affected with all of the smoke filling
the sky
environment canada has issued air
quality alerts for the region
because the smoke is so dense and it
will continue to build over the next 24
to 48 hours
and wildfire smoke is starting to fill
the sky here where we are south of
linton
which is likely from other hot spots
that are flaring up
and it speaks to how quickly this
situation can change
robin paul haysom near litton bc thanks
paul
in just a few hours cross-border travel
will become a little easier
as of midnight fully vaccinated
canadians won't need to quarantine when
they return home from international
travel
abigail beeman breaks down what you need
to know before you head out on a summer
vacation
the canada border services agency is
beefing up staff at crossings prepared
for an
influx of travelers when the rules
change at 1201 monday morning
there could be you know some impacts to
the time it takes across the border and
we invite people to be patient
if you're a canadian or otherwise exempt
from restrictions
and you're fully vaccinated by a health
canada approved jab
you'll be able to skip the hotel
quarantine and the full 14 day
quarantine
as well as the day 8 test you still need
to provide proof of a negative pcr test
and take another when you arrive you
have to enter the test result and proof
of vaccination into a new version of the
arrive can app
downloadable at 1201 as well any
unvaccinated children traveling with you
still need to quarantine at home for 14
days
but can skip the hotel if you haven't
been able to travel up until now and you
weren't able to travel and enter canada
on july 4th
that doesn't change on july 5th those
restrictions remain
and you still can't come into canada
mentally it was affecting us mostly like
you know
the pandemic is being there on one layer
and the other layer like
not being able to reunite bashir amin is
a syrian refugee living in montreal a
temporary resident ineligible for a
visit by his partner of
five years chloe bordewick in boston
i've been fully vaccinated for months
you know i'm like ready to go pick up
any time now and every month we've
changed our plans again and again and
again it's disrupted our work it's
disrupted our mental health it's
disrupted
as i said our ability to plan for a
future together and and that's been
really devastating
frustrated too that the original metric
of 75 percent for a first dose and 20
for a second didn't move the needle if
the goal posts continually move
faith in public health becomes eroded
and public health requires the trust
of canadians to be effective the
prospect of having a bunch of people
coming up to pearson airport let's say
in toronto
and uh and not having to quarantine
and then have canadian citizens who are
only singly vaccinated because we're
behind americans on that having to
quarantine and that just strikes me as
politics and not science we will be
looking at how this works before we open
up to next steps
as for canadians looking to travel to
the u.s for a quick trip like
cross-border shopping that's still
a no-go the american land entry rules
barring non-essential travel haven't
changed either
now all eyes are on july 21st the next
shot at a broader border reopening for
both sides
robin abigail beeman in ottawa thanks
abigail
in the u.s americans are celebrating
independence day with a little more
freedom this year
president joe biden's goal of having 70
percent of adults vaccinated with at
least one shot by july
4th was so close but the white house is
still urging anyone who hasn't been
immunized to do so because of concerns
over the delta variant
jennifer johnson reports americans are
riding a wave of freedom
celebrating the country's independence
and that they're free from covet 19
lockdowns
after a whole year of following the
rules
not going out and now we're finally safe
enough to be out see other people
july 4 2021 is a star contrast to 2020
with 2.2 million people traveling on
planes friday
the highest since the pandemic began we
didn't really expect
it to be all this crowded friends and
families are reuniting
optimistic the worst of the pandemic is
behind them two-thirds of american
adults have gotten at least one dose of
a vaccine
but a new poll shows 74 percent of those
who are unvaccinated
are unlikely to ever get immunized if
you look at the number of deaths about
99.2 percent
of them are unvaccinated most all of
these
are avoidable and preventable experts
say full food and drug administration
approval
rather than the current emergency use of
the vaccines
might help persuade the reluctant a lot
of individuals that don't want to yet
get the vaccine
view it as experimental and they cite
the fact that this is still under
emergency use is a big reason why
they want to wait and see 18 of the 20
states with the lowest vaccination rates
are led by republican governors
many who supported former president
donald trump who often downplayed the
virus
some state leaders are emphasizing the
importance of getting vaccinated
as the delta variant spreads in our
state which is concerning
hospitalizations are rising again
we have 89 percent of those over the age
of 65. so we feel really good about that
and our death rates have come down
because of that but we desperately need
more
with cobit 19 still killing over 9 700
americans in june
experts say be wary this virus is still
among us
jennifer johnson global news washington
many parts of canada are reaching
vaccination milestones turning the
corner towards a somewhat normal summer
but in other countries the delta variant
is stoking fresh fears
of a kova 19 flare-up take europe 63
percent of the population there
still hasn't had the first dose and as
ross lord reports
it's a race between the vaccine and the
variant
with the third wave of covet 19 petering
out in canada the narrative
is shifting to positive milestones like
nova scotia poised to celebrate one
million vaccine doses administered
but as provinces and the federal
government make new rules for
international travelers
there are new reminders of why some
parts of the world are a long way from
returning to normal
the world health organization's regional
director for europe
says covet 19 cases in the region are no
longer dropping
he warns there will be yet another wave
unless people stay disciplined and get
vaccinated
about 63 percent of people in europe
have not had their first dose of vaccine
while we should all recognize the
progress made across most countries in
the region
we must also acknowledge that we are by
no means
out of danger kluge warns an increase in
socializing
travel and large sports events could
cause outbreaks of the fast spreading
delta variant
already russia is reporting its highest
coveted numbers since january
more than 25 000 new cases on sunday
driven by the delta variant there were
five consecutive days of record high
deaths
including almost 700 on saturday
some countries are feeling more
confident in the united kingdom the
wimbledon tennis tournament will allow
maximum capacity crowds
from the quarterfinals onward the uk
government is planning to ease pandemic
restrictions on july 19th
based on the success of its vaccination
campaign
i don't particularly want to wear a mask
i
don't think a lot of people uh enjoy
doing it
we will be moving into a phase though
where these will be matters of personal
choice
contrast people in brazil took to the
streets
in the thousands demanding the
resignation of president
jair bolsonaro they accused bolsonaro of
mismanaging the pandemic
allowing covert 19 to run rampant and
kill more than a half million people
scenes that seem to validate canada's
regulated approach to covert 19
and step by step reopening ross lord
global news in japan crews are searching
for
survivors after a mud flight hit a town
southwest of tokyo
so far 19 people have been rescued but
rain is hampering efforts
more than a thousand people including
members of japan's military have been
brought in to help with the search
at least two people are dead and more
than 20 are missing
yesterday's slide sent a tsunami-like
torrent of mud into dozens of buildings
and vehicles
the philippines has been hit with the
worst military disaster
in decades an air force c-130 plane
crashed while trying to land
killing at least 42 troops and three
civilians witnesses say the aircraft
missed the runway
several people were seen jumping out of
the plane before it hit the ground
in a fiery explosion 96 people were on
board
many were troops who had just undergone
basic training
in florida demolition crews are racing
to bring down a section of the collapsed
condo
to open up new areas for rescue teams
it's been 11 days since the catastrophe
at the champlain towers
24 bodies have been recovered but 121
people
are still unaccounted for the search was
paused on saturday so specialists could
put explosives into a section of the
building
that is expected to be demolished at any
moment
tropical storm elsa is making its way
towards southern florida
the state could begin feeling the
effects tomorrow elsa was downgraded
from a hurricane after damaging
thousands of homes in barbados and
killing at least three people
in the caribbean a settlement has been
reached to release the container ship
that blocked the suez canal for six days
back in march
the details are yet to be revealed but
the ever given will be allowed to sail
away
on july 7th the suez canal authority had
seized the japanese owned ship
over demand for compensation the
blockage sparked a supply crisis
that cost the global economy billions of
dollars
coming up who is this first nation grand
chief and what does she hope
to accomplish
police in kingston ontario were called
out early this morning to break up a
large party
roughly 300 people were at a home in the
city's university district
outdoor social gatherings in ontario
remain capped at 25 people and
indoor gatherings are limited to just
five so far no charges have been laid
but the police are still investigating
the mohawks of ganaway have made history
the community about 10 kilometers south
of montreal has elected a new leader to
replace late grand chief joseph norton
and assel carpenter explains for the
first time the council will be led
by a woman gunnawage
has voted for change on saturday the
mohawk community of montreal's
south shore voted for gasa nahawi sky
deer
as their first woman grand chief she
replaced his longtime
grand chief joe norton who passed away
last august
i think that it's fabulous that they
have a
woman now chief and that's in the
history for many in the community
her win both as a woman and a member of
the lgbtq2s community
is monumental mike dillel former grand
chief who was just re-elected saturday
as one of 11 council chiefs
says it's a sign the community is
evolving it's a great achievement i mean
it's a sign of the times in terms of
change
we are a conservative community by
nature and
take this step forward i think is large
deer isn't new to politics having served
12 years
as a council chief she wasn't available
for interviews
sunday but on saturday she said one of
her priorities
would be looking at governance finding a
way to return to
governing structure you know that's more
reflective of who we are
as first nations people she underscored
the need for governments to do
more to support hers and other first
nations communities
this isn't a handout this is what's owed
to us and it's a drop in the bucket
compared to what we should be getting
another priority to help guide the
community through the trauma
of residential schools our community
right now
is in a very sad state with all of the
you know recent discoveries of these
children across turtle island
and that you know right now what we need
is uh
is healing her father who observes
traditional rituals says his daughter
follows in his footsteps
she speaks the language for instance he
believes she is well placed to
not only help unite her village but to
help build bridges
between it and the outside communities
my advice to my daughter
would be to never
come from a place of fear ever sky deer
steps into her new role as grand
chief monday phil carpenter global news
ganaway still ahead did you feel sick
after your kova 19 shots
we look into the different reactions
more than 34 percent of eligible
canadians are now fully vaccinated
and some people have experienced side
effects others have felt nothing at all
so does the lack of reaction mean less
protection our health reporter jamie
morocco
is looking into this tonight
for months amanda ferguson who is
immunocompromised has been part of a
study out of toronto sinai health
monitoring her covid19 antibody levels
post vaccine
i wanted that sign that my body and my
immune system was working
and other than a little bit of fatigue i
didn't really feel much
living with crohn's that lack of
symptoms after her first pfizer shot had
her worried she wasn't building immunity
but her results gave her good news 16
days roughly past the first shot then
you saw
oh my gosh i'm protected doctors say
reactions to the covet-19 vaccines range
some people feel slight soreness at the
injection site others suffer from muscle
aches headaches and fever
i don't think that people who haven't
had this really robust
reaction after vaccine are
need to be concerned at all and while
most experts agree earl brown a
professor of virology at the university
of ottawa notes
immunity is linked to inflammation the
vaccine has to stimulate inflammation
that your body
responds to so you don't have to feel
unwell
but you have to have an activated immune
system from your vaccine
brown also points out different vaccines
can prompt different reactions
it is a dance when you're vaccinating
getting
a vaccine which will stimulate your
immune response
sufficiently but not excessively after
her second dose of pfizer ferguson says
she was left with a sore arm
and more anxiety as she awaited her
levels the results came back loud and
clear that not only like i had a good
amount after the first shot but then i
had a really good number after the
second
peace of mind she says and proof the
size of the reaction
doesn't equal the amount of protection
jamie morocco global news toronto
up next this dog knows how to heal we'll
tell you about the four-legged therapy
for hospital staff
a k-9 companion in calgary is scoring
points with hospital staff
tucker has been boosting the spirits of
those working on the front lines during
one of the most stressful times
in history here's lauren pullen on the
free form of therapy
that's working wonders in emergency
rooms from coast to coast
doctors expect the unexpected but this
was different
we were not only at war with this
coveted virus in the emergency
department
but we as healthcare workers could be
the casualties
a front-line fight with stress like
never before
we lost a lot of sleep not knowing what
was going to happen
we never knew what was around the corner
for health care workers and those
needing critical care during the
pandemic
there are days that are simply
overwhelming but just when it all seems
to be too much
it's kind of like having a movie star
walk in
it's it's magic some unconditional love
when it's needed the most tucker was my
retirement president
he's my best friend larry gertzen wanted
to share some of that four-legged
affection so for the past four years the
pair has volunteered at one of calgary's
busiest hospitals
and now everyone knows tucker by name
armed with his own official badge the
seven-year-old english lab roams the
hospital halls
gladly greeting healthcare workers and
visiting patients for some quality
time and stress relief just a way for
you know for us to kind of escape
even if it's for the five minutes of
getting a pet in with
with tucker let's go quick quick
tucker is the high point of my week
during the height of the pandemic the
hospital had to press pause on the
visits but it was one of the first
volunteer programs brought back when it
was safe
and for good reason canadian research
shows that patients
across the board feel better when the
dog is around
both even the pain level seemed to
moderate just by having the dog
there and even for larry it's just a
good feeling
and i know it helps me
a little compassion care and even a
keepsake
and of course we give them a trading
card and i go through a lot of these
and in a time and place where smiles
aren't always easy to come by
that little bit of tucker tlc makes all
the difference
good boy are you a good boy
yeah lauren pulling global news calgary
what a sweet story that is global
national for this sunday night i'm robin
gill
tonight your canada is deep cove in
north vancouver we'd love to see your
corner of the country so please keep
sending your photos
to viewers at globalnational.com thank
you for watching
and i'll see you next weekend have a
great night
[Music]
you